This episode is supported by "Blue Apron".
We all have habits that we love to break
Whether it's biting your nails, smoking or eating late at night
But why is it so hard to break these habits
You may think that your day is made up of
Deliberate and conscious decisions
But in fact, a university study found that
45% of your daily behaviors are actions you repeat every day
And tend to be carried out in the same location. These are your habits.
Habits are attributed to one of the most primitive structures in your mind
"Base nodes", the same area that helps control operations
Such as breathing and swallowing
In an MIT experiment, a mouse sits behind a maze gate (T)
To his left is a piece of chocolate.
When he clicks the door, the mouse explores the maze
Inhale and scratch the walls
First he explores the right then to the left, eventually finding the chocolates.
A survey of the base contract shows that he is working ferociously
Throughout the whole process.
But after a week of training,
The mouse immediately runs towards the chocolate as soon as you click the gate.
At this point, there is very little brain activity once the portal is clicked
The brain does not work again until it reaches the chocolate
Our brain seeks to reduce effort and space
This type of automatic brain behavior is referred to as "CHANKING - ORDER"
It aims to usually create a new pattern in brain cells.
It's like a task you do every day and no longer needs to think about
Brush your teeth or retreat from your own path
Skills that were difficult to control but now become automatic.
This process is 3 steps
Step 1 is the "signal" that is for the mouse clicking on the gate
Step 2 is the 'style' jogging across the maze
Step 3 is the "bonus", in this case chocolate.
The "signal" and "reward" are eventually intertwined to create "expectation" and "desire"
Another basic part of habits
Because we go into automatic mode during patterns
Our brain depends entirely on participation in decision-making
Our habits will automatically unfold every time there is a signal
These habits can be so entrenched that rewards do not require to be good.
A study on the habit of popcorn eaters in films found that they were minimally affected
Hungry or how much they loved the food
They ate the same amount of popcorn regardless of whether they were old or fresh
Our habits often outweigh what we know is good for us
For example, a study on the US "TAKE 5" campaign to encourage citizens to eat 5 fruits and vegetables a day
Found that the program was effective in educating the public
But the assessment found that it did not change the US income, where only 11% achieved the goal.
I changed people's intentions but not their habits
So what should you do?
Charles Duheij, author of "The Power of the Habit," offers an example of buying biscuits every day at about 3:15 pm at work
The "signal" is the third hour, but the "reward" is somewhat more complicated
Cookies can also be a pack of many bonuses
It can be a relief from hunger or an increase in energy to satisfy your appetite for something sweet
Or it can be a nice break from work
Or even an opportunity to talk to people
"Dohij" wanted to break his habit of biscuits after some trial and error
Discover that what you really aspire to is the socialization that came from buying biscuits
If about 3 was up and find someone to chatter with him for 10 minutes instead
Using the same "reference" and the same "reward" of socialization
He was able to break the biscuits normally
But what about customs that you do not always notice
Such as biting your nails
Psychologists suggest that you first think "when" you bite your nails
Are you nervous?
Or are you bored?
In the case of boredom, the fingernails provide physical stimulation
So, after that you need to mark each time in your day you feel bored and you have to force your fingernails to bite
Maybe this is 5 times a day
Maybe 28
But then want to implement an equal response
Whenever you feel the urge to bite, immediately put your hands in your pockets
Then find a replacement that provides quick physical stimulation
Such as rubbing your arm
Or tap your joints on the desk
This allows a replacement usually with a "reward" similar but also uses the same "cue"
So when you're ready to accept a bad habit, just remember
Know what your body really wants, and use the same signal and reward that serves the right purpose
Be patient to build this new habit
- Now, if your bad habit includes food, the sponsors of today's video
They are "Blue Apron". They have the best solution for you
- Currently giving the first 100 people to score
For our link, you can find it below. Discount $ 40
For the first two weeks serving the food - "Blue Apron" is not just
A great way to be health conscious with your food
But it helps you cook more at home, which is something
We suffer from it in our lives. They are actually plugging in
Fresh ingredients from the farm to your home door
Packed ice-cream
Ingredients you need for recipes. In my opinion I think
It's very cool. Not only will you get delicious meals
Healthy, but will help you learn culinary
Because recipes change every week
Step by step and gorgeous followed. There are also many different kinds of plants
To choose from depending on the number of people who cook them, whether they like
A family or couple like us, only two people
They have 8 meals a week, and all meals take less than
40 minutes. Thank you very much for "Blue Apron" for support
this video. Be sure to sign up and we'll see you again
For a new animated video. -See you later.